So everything you're watching right now
was generated with a text prompt.
There's no After Effects, no timeline,
and no key framing. So today I'm just
going to show you how to set it up, use
it, and create your own motion graphics
with simple text prompts. So first off,
you are going to need at least a pro
subscription in Claude. And you're going
to have to download the desktop app. And
you can do that by just going to the
website and downloading the Mac or the
Windows option. Then once you've got it
downloaded, you're going to click on the
code here. And it's going to come up
with this screen. And you're going to
have to choose a folder location where
you want to save everything that you're
about to make. So I've just saved it in
one of my YouTube stock folders. And
then we're going to go to the GitHub,
which I've put in the description below.
Copy the URL and paste it into Claude.
Just make sure you're on Opus 4.6 when
you do this as well. Then you're just
going to type install this Claude skill.
We're going to be rebuilding Remotion
videos here. And can you please build me
an example? And this is just to test
that it's working and making sure that
when it gives you the example, it's
something that you could actually use.
And then it's going to ask you a lot of
times if you want to allow things that
are happening. So just click always
allow for project and just keep pressing
enter when it's going through these
steps. Okay. And once that's done, it's
going to open up a local host and then
show you the video file that it's
created. The first one is going to be
very simple cuz it's basically just
showing you what it can actually do. And
now that you know that the remotion is
working, you can start creating your
first animation video. So for an
example, I'm just going to use Apple
because they have a lot of nice and easy
to grab products out there. So, I'm just
going to type in I want a motion video
graphics, a motion graphics video
showcase where each one of our products
comes into frame one at a time
surrounded by high-end motion graphics.
I'm very tired, so my prompt is not the
best. But, let's see what it can
actually do with something very simple
and very vague like this. Now, it might
ask you if you want to download the
Chrome extension. You can do it with or
without. It just goes about it a
different way. So, it's completely up to
you. And then it'll come up with a plan
and tell you what it's actually thinking
of designing for this. So, if you're
happy with the plan, you can just
approve it. So, what it's done is not
the worst. I mean, some of the motion
graphics are actually pretty cool, but
what we would want to do now is we
obviously wouldn't want to just use
these icons. So, we'd want an actual
iPhone. We'd want a MacBook. We'd want a
proper iPad and a watch. And I think
we'd want more of a gradient style
background in the background. So, let's
get those assets together and hop back
into Claude now. Okay. So, the good
thing about this is it can actually
access files on your computer now. So,
I'm going to get the transparent PGs and
rename them to what it told me to rename
them. And then when they're up in the
folder that it suggested, I will just
come back and tell it that the images
are now ready. So I'm going to create a
1080x 1080 project in Canva and just
drop all my images that I want to use in
there. Just change the background to
black just so I can see that the
background remover has worked. Now you
can do this in anything. You can do it
in Photoshop or whatever else other
image editor you use. I just use Canva
cuz the background remover is pretty
decent. So once I've got all the images
in the folder and I've given them the
correct names like it suggested, I'm
just going to say all images are in the
folder, please add a
please add a radial gradient background
to the entire thing as well. Now this is
much better. I think that happens a bit
too fast, but I could obviously give it
more instructions and change that up if
I wanted to. But for the purpose of this
video, I'm just going to move along now
because I think that is a really good
example of something you could do. And
then to render it, you just come over
here to render, choose what codec you
wanted, and there you go. It's rendered
you a HD motion graphic that you can
bring into Da Vinci Resolve and then add
all of your sound effects, your music,
and whatever you wanted just to make
this better. Okay, so let's test out
another example. So I work a lot with
people who are promoting social media
businesses. So, so I've copied an image
here from the internet just to show what
the Instagram insize screen looks like.
Now, I'm going to say I want a motion
graphics video showing accounts reach
going from 0 to 48,600. The circle and
the followers and the non-followers
number grow while it plays. I also just
added that the lines underneath as well
are going to grow and then just see what
it comes up with just so I can have a
nice animated motion graphic of
Instagram insights. Well, sometimes it
might give you something that looks
absolutely like this. So, you just need
to give it a bit of a kick up the
backside. And all I said was I sent the
image again and I said this looks
nothing like the image I sent you. I
wanted it to look like that exactly.
Then obviously it gives it another go
and it comes back with this. And while
it still might need a little bit of
tweaking, I think this is fantastic cuz
it would have taken me probably 2 3
hours in After Effects to do. The next
use case we're going to do is adding
subtitles to our videos. So I'm just
going to copy my video file that I want
to add subtitles to into the public
stock folder that it asked me to upload
my assets to. And then I'm going to have
this video open in Da Vinci Resolve and
just go over to timeline AI tools create
subtitles from audio. And once I've got
my subtitles done, just rightclick
export subtitle. Go back to that public
folder and just give it the same kind of
name dams subtitles. And then I'm going
to come back into Claude and say and
then in Claude I've already asked it if
it can create some animated subtitles
for me. And then I'm just going to say I
have put the video and subtitle
in the public folder. And it's asking me
to paste the transcript. So I can just
paste the transcript as well. That's
fine. I have the video and SRT file.
Perfect. The only thing you're going to
want to make sure is if you do do this,
you're going to obviously want to check
your subtitle spelling before you export
it because Da Vinci most likely has got
a couple of spelling errors in there and
you won't be able to edit them in this
final output. Flip it to Jippeting. And
now we've got the output. So, it's
exported the output to the out folder,
and I've just dragged this into Da Vinci
Resolve. So, let's play and see how the
subtitles look.
>> I saw a clinician yesterday who might be
just like you. She knows how to do the
procedures. She's great with patients.
She doesn't have a thriving clinic yet
for one reason,
>> and that has worked amazingly. So, what
if we wanted a different style? Then we
just go back into Claude. So, I'm just
trying a bit of a different style and
make it more Instagram style with, you
know, different sized words and a
background border and see how that
looks. I saw a clinician yesterday who
might be just like you. She knows
[music] how to do the procedures. She's
great with patients. She doesn't have a
thriving clinic yet for one reason. So,
it came back with a really interesting
idea. Obviously, I'd want to move the
subtitles down. So, I'd tell it that.
And I think it happens a little bit too
harshly, but this is genuinely amazing
because whatever you can think of, you
can prompt it and it will come up with
new subtitle ideas for you to be unique
and not copying Alex Horosi every single
time. Okay, so another one. We've
already shown that you can do it with
the Apple products. But what about
something that's more of an app or
courses and things like that? Well,
we've got the Sweat Factor website here.
So, I'm just going to paste this in and
say, "Make a promo for the
sweatfactor.com website. Use the photos
and videos that they have, their logo,
horizontal, same brand, font, and
colors. CTA is 50% off your first
month." And let's say I want this to be
around 30 seconds for a promo. And let's
see what it comes up with with this one.
Okay, it finished rendering. It put it
into my files. Let's have a quick look.
So, it managed to take the video. It's
copied the text from the website. It's
added in the photos of all the different
styles of training. Put in the trainers.
It's highlighted them all. It's moving
around. I mean, this is this is a pretty
damn good job. There are certain things
I would like to tweak on it. I'd spend a
little bit more time on it, but to say
that this all came out of a text prompt
is honestly insane. So the last one I'm
going to show you is just an easy one
and it's basically what if I wanted
something with a transparent background.
So you can't export transparent videos
from this. It doesn't work. I've tried
it. But there is a way around it. So
let's say all I want is a call to
action. So a bouncy button that
basically says sign up to the webinar
below. So let's go to Claude. So I'm
just making it create a 1080 by350 for
Instagram ad sizes. A button in the
bottom third that just bounces in, fades
in, and says sign up to the webinar
below. So let's let it create this.
Okay. Okay. So, I didn't even ask it to
this time, but it did say it's a
transparent background, so I can overlay
it on. So, let's see if it manages to
fix this. So, I've got the webinar
button here that it's made. Let's drag
it over the top. No, it didn't work. It
still has the black background, but I
mean, it looks really good. So, we're
just going to go back into Claude now to
fix this. So, I'm just going to say
transparent MP4 doesn't work. Can you
export me a sequence of transparent PGs
so I can import it as a sequence in its
own folder? And once it says it's ready,
I'm going to come into the media tab in
Da Vinci Resolve. Then I'm going to find
where it saved my button to, which is in
this folder here. Now, if you're seeing
this as lots of individual images, just
come to frame display mode and just make
sure that it's set to sequence instead
of individual.
Then I'm just going to drag it into my
stock folder and go back over to the
edit page. Then I can just drag the
button over the top. And there we go.
We've got a transparent animated PNG.
Honestly, this is just some of the stuff
that you can do in Claude. There is so
many different things that you can try
and it's honestly amazing that we can do
all this with text promps. So yeah, I
hope this helped and I hope you enjoy.